Denise Richards officially takes the
plunge and is joining only fans
I guess it's like mother like daughter
the saying ringing true for this Duo the
news comes just one week after 18 year
old Sammy Sheen did the same whatever
they want to do I just want them happy
and follow their passion and their heart
Denise announced on Instagram Thursday
she's launching her own page now posting
a video of herself taking a dip in the
ocean in an all-white Ensemble captioned
ready here we go hashtag only fans right
now she's charging subscribers 25 a
month and already has two posts and
Counting so I would want to be my true
authentic self the choice to join the
platform was simple for Denise to her
there's not a huge difference between
only fans and posting bikini pics on
Instagram less than a week ago Denise
stood up for her daughter Sammy who
received criticism for creating an
account on the platform known for
sharing adult content the 51 year old
came to her daughter's defense in full
support saying she wishes she had
Sammy's confidence at her age Denise
wrote quote I also can't be judgmental
of her choices I did wild things and
Playboy quite frankly her father
shouldn't be either I think we just want
our child to pursue whatever would make
them happy you know and if that's what
they believe
would make them happy then then
absolutely as long as they have
something to fall back on some real job
guess this job wouldn't make the cut for
Charlie while the actor has always
supported his kids Showbiz aspirations
Charlie spoke out about disapproving of
his daughter Sammy having an only fans
account in a statement to E.T Charlie
said quote I do not condone this but
since I'm unable to prevent it I urge
her to keep it classy creative and not
sacrifice her Integrity have they gotten
any of the Showbiz bug would they want
to be and go into acting Sammy I think
would be more interested in directing
and photography Denise quickly clapped
back telling us in a statement quote
Sammy is 18 and this decision wasn't
based on whose house she lives in all I
can do as a parent is guide her and
trust her judgment but she makes her own
choices I don't ever want to push my
kids to do something they don't want to
do but I encourage them if that is
something they want to do then to try it
and explore different things only time
will tell whether Denise's new only fans
is a hit but it looks like she's pretty
confident in her own skin
to make sure
[Music]
[Music]